Stephen Paul Jobs yes that is his real
name was an incredible visionary
he transformed the computer mobile and
music industries he single-handedly
brought up all back from the dead and
transformed it into one of the richest
and most influential companies in the
world today but here's some things you
might not know about Steve Jobs and
Apple Steve had amazing attention to
detail one day he called Google to tell
them the yellow gradient in their Oh
wasn't quite right
Steve persuaded PepsiCo President John
Sculley to become Apple CEO in 1983 by
telling him do you want to sell sugared
water all your life or do you want to
change the world
the irony is John Sculley later fired
Steve Jobs from Apple in 1985 but Steve
Jobs claimed that being fired was the
best thing that ever happened to him
because it led to the most creative
period of his life during Jobs time away
from Apple Computer he was a busy bunny
he started a brand new computer company
or next and bought a small book soon to
be large animation studio called
Pixar Pixar later went on to strike a
game-changing deal with Walt Disney and
created the legendary Toy Story next was
eventually brought by Apple and Jobs
returned to Apple in 1996 Jobs was
obsessed with the quality of design on
his deathbed he refused to wear his
oxygen mask because he didn't like its
design Apple sell approximately 10 iOS
devices
every second and that's not even
including their mutt range Apple
computer was started by two college
dropouts Steve Jobs and his buddy Steve
Wozniak they launched a company from
Steve's family garage in 1976 Apple's
factory in China where iPhones are
manufactured employs 230 thousand people
there have been 18 suicides of the plant
suicide nets are now in place to prevent
any more employees from taking their own
lives
the very first Apple logo so Isaac
Newton sitting under a tray with an
apple about to fall on his head
Apple made the very first mass-market
digital camera called the Apple
quick-take it was launched in 1994
during Steve Jobs's absence from the
company
it's had 0.3 megapixels the camera was a
massive failure and jobs removed it from
the market upon his return to Apple the
first Apple Computer appropriately named
the Apple 1 was released in 1976 it cost
six hundred and sixty six dollars and 66
cents only 200 were ever made the third
founder of Apple yes there were three
Ronald Wayne sold his share of the
company in 1976 for a measly $800 his
shares would have been worth an
estimated 35 billion today Apple is
worth six hundred and twenty four
billion dollars in fact Apple now has
more disposable cuts than the entire US
Treasury if the iPad were manufactured
in the US because of the major
differences in wages running costs and
manufacturing costs it would cost a
staggering fourteen thousand nine
on $70 jobs was born to it our Father he
was later adopted by a middle-class
couple Clara and Botox he grew up in
California Steve's first job was a video
game designer for Avatar II he used the
money he earned from Atari to travel to
India for a spiritual retreat in 1974 it
is rumored he returned home wearing
traditional Indian clothing and how to
save her jobs became a Buddhist until
next time
you